I'm still embrace money welcome back to
last of us left behind we just played
through the first 30 minutes it's pretty
awesome so far I don't know why I'm
still talking I'm so sorry okay I gotta
say it feels Oh
I'm low health that's what I was gonna
say well I guess we got a shot so need
to get health stuff for Joel cuz Joel is
being a goddamn slacker again what is
this
I mean we could probably climb over I
would probably climb over all right
well let's say Joel even though we
already know we are gonna save Joel but
I like how they mishmash the stories or
whatever prequels in it's in all its
glory it's all [ __ ] it's it's nice to
actually do something that spins off the
actual story I don't know that's a kitty
cat
Keller wood bricks yeah I almost got it
almost got it
maybe next time you brought a cat or a
dog dog prison I used to have a cat all
right so goddamn fat that can't do my
it's kind of like Edgar no anyway okay
goddamn kick
if that cat tried something again I
swear to God I will kill him I don't
like that we have ammo because that
means we're gonna run into zombies soon
is this special Cola oh it's a note here
you want to read that you can go and
pause it's too far away I can't really
see we go alright let's go oh hello
thought she was gonna sniff it or some
[ __ ] maybe I can find some I'm sure we
will honey
I'm sure we man maybe in that truck with
a special color off-course
stalker I like that would you call them
these days kids no you just gotta keep a
low profile
I don't remember if they they care about
the flashlight or not
alright god all right we have bricks
there's one coming up
I don't like this at all
you know why you know what you know what
we're gonna do how oh how the [ __ ] did
she see me though seriously that's kind
of bullcrap
don't tell me thank you sir
please stay that that be great
where's the third one
how I could I went better but
they're more yeah
the thing with stalkers you can't really
stop them I don't think it leaves if
there's water here but in the future I
will try and play this self porn I said
door wolf they do drop a lot of ammo ma
hey goes yeah okay find some gas all
right gas time I was hoping that truck
would have it wrong
I show by that we haven't been here
right let's check it out oh hello
No hello should we go in here [ __ ]
locked oh [ __ ] what are we gonna hear
though switch I think we just need to
find that hey okay I got to predict the
future now we're gonna find the guys I'm
gonna start the engine and then there's
gonna come Sam B's from from that door
cuz they're gonna hear the noise hi Hey
we'll see ah jackpot I think they do
this take the hose and just siphon it
out right
okay I think Ellie likes to get hiring
sniffing I should do it I'm just saying
it's okay le you don't have to lie to me
that's suck you come on
oh okay let's do it Brum Brum oh don't
touch electric water
why not oh we're gonna play like games
it's my favorite game my favorite game
is the game where you apply tonight boy
my favorite game now we can go when here
because you started it and that means we
can go out the latigo but I remember
specifically there was like some potato
chips here don't want to miss out on the
potato chips girl never won I miss
Swedish potato chips man those were the
best we had like sour cream and onion
they don't have those in UK
yeah but weird ones see onions keep
looking straight everything's gonna be
fine I'm not gonna fall into that water
Friday would fry like a shrimp I think
we need a jump down alright here we go
ha me I'm pretty sure we can actually
walk
ah well how do you do miss it inside
some potato chips for me thank you I'll
take that
oh okay I guess I didn't pretty future
well hey I'm sorry I'm not a wizard
okay God what do you want from me
whoa shabby oh that's a hard core
[ __ ] gaming rig right there okay now
we have a problem that's the way out how
do I get there you can walk on these
right Oh God yeah that's so sure um okay
what do we get if we can jump maybe from
there yeah that looks like I'll do it
that looks like LM doing a trick I don't
know how they [ __ ] we're gonna jump from
here though
we're gonna have to climb from there
nice jumping Ali nice nice very smooth
hmm should I check in here for loot like
I should
oh I'm probably need this whoa hey
Jeannie it's pure strikes again Oh
how does she pull me why don't we why
are we gonna put these I mean I don't
need them right why would I need it
maybe there's more than one way to do it
okay there we go
[Laughter]
that explains it very good yeah see I'm
ahead of time in this game in doing
great brows prana you feel that
different [ __ ] taking all the credit is
that how you always do it that's okay
whoa yeah that's a nice gun question is
if we can do this jump or not there you
go there's the answer
oh I'm so [ __ ] dumb if we're telling
me - weren't you all right yeah okay yep
I'm not I'm not gonna pretend that I'm
Oh God
I could almost here we go you go Guerra
you go Elliot I didn't take that long
under over
considering how easily everything falls
off in this place I'd be pretty
terrified walking on these vents man
it's for that ambience and that's so
sure I like it be careful early you
don't know what's in they I haven't
explained the cats
here we go baby what is this place
Pet Bell that's so nice
that's so nice I love pads I would keep
you as a pet but I don't keep dead
animals inside yet
I forget how swaggy they are man don't
like the swag lords 2009 oh he saw me
right Oh a guy
it's [ __ ] clothes man don't do that
again pants it's not worth a but just be
crazy don't forget that's a nice picture
of a goat oh it's a dog well it looks
like a go and don't judge okay all right
what do we get we got three of them
should be okay yeah we can do this
these are stalkers though these [ __ ]
are clickers Oh God yeah that's the
clicker okay let's get the stalkers and
then this [ __ ] the critical occur in the
ass the aids face I meant no no we're
okay hey god damn it I'm full of ammo Oh
God oh god that was he doing so yelling
at the other guy and he's like crying
shake your best yet you got yet but imma
go ahead look at my face
it's goddamn fabulous you will never be
this pretty look at me walk I walk like
I mean it Oh [ __ ] to the family why is
he crying over there
why are you crying zambese don't cry I
think okay we got it we're gonna do this
yeah hello
good night that's how we don'twe hell
yeah
oh that's pretty good that's pretty good
let's be honest it's pretty [ __ ] yeah
don't squeeze your fingers what yeah we
accomplished nothing really oh yeah we
got there really [ __ ]
I swear clickers are like drunk people
that are late to the party they think
that's cool they think think this [ __ ]
but really they're just really ugly and
annoying why does it come here don't
come here I'm busy being swag you know
the other one didn't hear that right I
think you did and I think he's really
[ __ ] pissed
Oh God
how can they know
okay we can do this yo ha
no he knows that little [ __ ] come on I
need a break
I need to break really bad all right
[ __ ] that guy
let's get a break oh god I knew a break
his name was Ray you had a chick that I
faked in the bath uh-oh
what's your favorite color
- whatever okay okay
orange asking zambese what the favorite
color is confuses them they're already
probably really confused okay that's
good was that all of them okay that was
surprisingly painless yeah
foot marks in the snow girl book
magazine this now
all right helicopter let's do this
I don't like where this is going okay
we're gonna cut back to the other girl
I'm pretty sure soon all right yeah
we're here okay that was that's cool
what do we got that how the hell are we
gonna reach it Holly are you crazy
Lau be cray you be Ukraine okay be cool
just what the hell Go Daddy no little
hop hey Jana you don't even know if
there's medical supply in there let's
bounce BX now
how are you going I'm not letting you go
are you ready
totally it's kind of interesting I the
economy - are you kidding
told you
that thing is bound to attract nah the
exterior lights don't work
how do you know this Firefly Melanie
told me all about it
this looks fancy want to try it
how can she fix her ponytail sure why
not
I'll be this one his name is princess
Thank You Riley come here now you got
this go that's adorable
come on get up here sit next to me all
right wait huh is it weird that I ship
them yeah that's weird
well I loved it so there oh I got
something else what is that hmm what did
the triangle say to the circle Oh what
is that
you're so pointless [ __ ] you you found
another pawn book what did the cannibal
get when you showed up to the party late
um a cold shoulder yeah that's for you
you know you might just be my favorite
person again just sayin
I know my girl just sayin my girl huh
that's thing huh all right you ready all
right all right I heard two peanuts
walked into a park one was assaulted you
bros remember from the first game she
kept telling puns I guess she got them
from this book yes like I'm reading a
book on anti-gravity and it's impossible
I'm glad I know sign language it's
become quite handy I forgot how to throw
a boomerang but it came back to me yeah
when a clock is hungry it goes back for
seconds
oh yeah it goes bad for seconds yeah I
forgot when the power went out at the
school the children were delighted okay
yeah they were obviously coy those two
men drinking battery acid it will soon
be charged oh yeah what is the pirate's
favorite letter I know this one no tis
to see the midgets psychic escaped
prison he was a small medium at large Oh
am i doing incline
anyway that's awesome how's this work
share on Facebook you know what you do
it so when did this epochal a happen I
figured Facebook wasn't invented how it
was cool friends are loved
maybe love you trying to woo me and your
dreams
let's go back oh okay as an angel okay
something creepy oh let's make an ugly
face okay okay and there we are again
what's a face maybe it prints our faces
in a book no oh we can just print our
pictures oh my god I can't believe is
actually gonna work No
hit me try okay Oh what just happened I
think we broke it
[Music]
you want to keep exploring hell yeah all
right press I'm talking like this
because might say sleeping sorry I can't
do a proper outro but if you want to
leave a like I would really appreciate
that and a lot of hugs a lot of kisses
I'll see you tomorrow in the next
episode sails impress real fast